I'm a huge huge huge huge proponent of
alternative education I love the
education businesses I Love Guru
businesses I love them comma as long as
they're being done well really focused
on the product and the customer I love
that and fundamentally like viewer
businesses are just education businesses
and they are sprouting all over the
place because the demand is unmet by the
formal education system the demand is
for skills that make money and so in one
good way I think Instagram and all that
stuff has made more people believe that
they can do it the downside is obviously
whenever you have upside you've got an
equal opposite reaction of people who
are scamming people and things like that
I think that the difference between a
scam and somebody who is trying to
deliver is intention I think there are
many well-hearted or well-intentioned
Educators who are really trying to do a
good job but they are poor teachers just
like there are people who love to teach
who are teachers and we're terrible at
teaching math and you probably had them
but they really wanted to help and they
just weren't that good at it and so I
have a little bit more of a heart for
for both sides of the equation here but
I do think that education is the way